We Begin this hour with the look inside
the mind of one of golf's biggest
Superstars two-time major winner Justin
Thomas the 30 year old PGA Tour veteran
is set to defend his PGA championship
title later this week right here on CBS
we spent some time with JT at his
hometown Golf Club outside Louisville
Kentucky we spoke about his legacy and
his family his relationship with Tiger
Woods and the state of golf and he was
able to give this beginner golfer a few
tips
when you are as talented as Justin
Thomas
you can make one of the most humbling
games on the planet look easy I can get
bailed out by a teammate I can't blame
anything on a teammate it's
whatever I do in this sport is all on me
while golf is an individual sport Thomas
has confessed Obsession for the game
comes from a very special place
where did your love for the game of golf
come from you know just growing up
around my dad just wanted to do whatever
he was doing ever since I first got that
plastic Club in my hand however old I
was seems like it's stayed there for
quite a while there's a special
relationship between you and your dad
he's more than just your father he's
your coach
what has it been like to share the love
of the game with him we definitely have
a very unique relationship in the sense
of
having to shut off sometimes the
father-son to student and the coach you
know we go out to eat it's father son
but we're out on the Range it's business
but we're trying to get some work done I
don't like the detached feeling Thomas
is featured in the new Netflix reality
Series pool swing we just left the golf
course and we're gonna go to the airport
and then we're gonna which gives fans a
rare look at a side of pro golfs off the
course relationships you don't typically
get to see do you believe that shows
like this
helps make the sport bigger for sure I
think and that was the hope and the goal
of it right I mean the amount of people
that I've had come up to me whether it's
not even necessarily about me it's about
other people in the show talking about I
don't know anything about golf I knew
nothing about golf I watched the show
and now I'm a fan
we spent the afternoon with JT and his
family at his childhood Golf Club
Harmony Landing Justin
thanks for being here where Thomas was
hosting his annual Junior tournament
thanks guys and while Thomas is
certainly focused on his legacy for one
of the best players in the world it's
not always top of mind I can't be out
there
teeing it up or in the middle of a round
on Thursday or Friday like oh you know I
got to become this part of history or I
need to win this so I can be on this
list but the end of the day we just
don't know that reality because golf is
a pickle game and you just don't know
what's going to happen
listen I appreciate the humility but I
mean it's just me and you talking forget
the cameras you know you're one of the
best in the world though right
yeah okay that's what I wanted to hear
baby
as an athlete I identify with that you
have coaches you have friends that are
players you have your caddy but when
you're stepping up to swing it's just
you
in the ball do you think about all of
these other things
or is it just Justin versus Justin you
know I think when everything's going
well and you're in a zone or you're
maybe on a little bit of a hot streak
it's easy right see Fairway hit Fairway
seagull make pot and going to the next
one and it's like well yeah I just got
63. they're really simple right there
the way you put it I know it does sound
simple but it never is that's the hard
part about golf the PGA Tour is the is
the best place to play in the world and
professional golf has entered a new
world this past year with rival Tour
live golf backed by a boatload of Saudi
money luring players away with massive
paychecks
but Thomas one of the most important
faces in golf has made this much clearer
the PGA Tour is the only place he'd like
to be there's a lot of talk about
equipment rollbacks pace of play Rival
leagues do you believe that the sport of
golf isn't a good place right now I do I
would say it's not as in good of a spot
as it was you know before Liv started
just for the sake of everybody being
there and not necessarily having any
kind of competition but
I mean I think that golf is in an
unbelievable place do you believe that
it was important for guys to just come
out and say you know it was a big bag of
money and
I wanted it versus this long drawn out
explanation for sure for me personally
just because I it's
it was very apparent it was very obvious
I mean the numbers people were getting I
mean it doesn't take a rocket scientist
to tell you why the decisions were made
but yeah I'm that's been my whole thing
is I'm like just at least come out and
say well I really is I don't need this
Spiel of why you're not right here
yeah that's how we do it
what if I told you at 10 years old you
would be great friends with the Great
Tiger Woods yeah I definitely wouldn't
believe that there's definitely moments
when I kind of pinch myself I mean we're
very similar in the sense that we're
both extremely competitive we're both
want to win we like to you know have fun
talk trash and you know I think uh
someone in his position he's probably
used to everybody you know bowing down
to him and wanting to do you know
whatever he needs and wants and I'm like
I'm not doing that like I'm I'll be one
of your friends and yeah 100 I would do
anything for him or his family but at
the same time I love giving him some
grief
and you know his son Charlie of course
you have a good eye for talent so you
tell me does Charlie have what it takes
he is extremely talented and 100 has
shots and ability that other kids that
age don't but he's so young you don't
know if he'll still want to play in
eight years or you know that's the
important part is he just keeps having
fun with it as you see tiger coach him
up is he the you know what just keep
having fun dad or is he what do you
think
all right enough said enough said and
you know what I'm fine with that because
I have two sons and I am hard on them
it's really cool watching the parent the
father side of him yeah as much as it is
the Golf Tiger it's like look I'm never
gonna do anything my kids that I'm not
going through you know I want to have
fun with Charlie and have a putting
contest and the losers got to do
whatever push-ups or something but it's
like I'm a part of that with them so
it's really cool to you know see how
much time and Carrie gives those kids
just turned 30 years old recently
married to his wife Jillian at one point
ranked number one in the world defending
his PGA championship title this week I
mean this young man just has it going
what a great personality and I also like
that he's so candid when you said you
know you're you know the best one of the
best he goes yeah cause most guys go
well you know no blah blah I love that
he owns it I love that he owns it Eminem
speaking of owning it what tips did he
give you golf wise
um he just told me to get as many reps
as I can that's what he kept talking
about you know because what we do as
golfers when we're beginning is we
perpetuate these bad habits he so he
told me if you can get on the course as
many times as you can it will make
yourself a better golfer but I struggle
with the sport you know even he said it
he said I feel like the best every day I
wake up but in a moment's time the game
will humble you yeah now imagine
somebody as novice as me he seems like
such a truth teller too I also like
seeing him seeing him and his dad yeah
yeah oh yeah I like that and this is
what I didn't know about golfers they
talk a lot of trash I thought that was
basketball football these guys are worse
than us that's for sure now listen you
can catch the coverage of the 105th PGA
Championship this weekend right here on
CBS and on Paramount Plus